let's see what's happening on the phones
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is the number our
first caller is also from the 6 1 7 area
code 6 1 7 who's this where you calling
from 6 1 7 are you there what about me
that is you oh hi my name is Tenley I'm
currently a student at UMass Amherst
alright my undergraduate stomping
grounds
my question is do you think people who
have like over sex offenders um like I
think they may be put on the registry
for life long do you think in that
aspect it's fair for them to be put on
registry like that whereas like people
who committed other crimes like rape I'm
sorry
rape or murder of anything like have
served like a certain amount of time and
then they have been out of jail there so
I'm not can you count can you restate
that last part of the question do you
think that uh like sex offenders do you
think they deserve like a chance to be
not like put on the registry like how if
you have committed rape there's no
registry for like like when you enter
that the community you don't just say
well I'm the rapist or directly okay and
that's why it mandated yeah so do you
think like it's fair for sex offenders
to have that same contact back on
treatment when they enter the community
of some sort so if we believe that when
you serve a prison sentence that that
sort of makes it gets you back to even
in other words you've paid your debt and
you are now debt free when you come out
of prison and there can be no further
impingements upon your liberty of any
kind that would be a case to argue that
the sex offender registry is wrong or
that it should be illegal for example
right because you've paid your debt to
society you committed a crime and then
you paid the price and that goes to zero
sum and now you kind of start from
scratch the reality is that that's not
how it works
at all you have people who are certainly
there's parole but even beyond that even
after because of things like three
strike laws even after you've served the
prison time for your second strike
you're not really back to zero because
if you get that third strike all of a
sudden you are still further in trouble
or made you know you're put in a worse
situation because of those first two
strikes so to speak so the first
question is do we believe that our legal
system our judicial system really puts
everybody back to zero once they've done
their prison time and the answer is of
course no in some states you're not even
allowed to vote after you've served your
prison sentence once you accept that
there's nothing particularly unfair
about the sex offender registry that
doesn't mean necessarily that in an
ideal system we would have it and that's
the main argument I get from callers
whenever we talk about this they say if
you've paid your debt to society then it
should be completely wiped out in terms
of the future influence on your life
that's not the case in any other way so
if you believe that there should be no
sex offender registry then that means
that there should be no accounting for
prior convictions when you commit
another crime that means that there
should be no restrictions on your
ability to vote once you get out of
prison some would argue even when you're
in prison you should be allowed to vote
so I think that I don't know too much
about whether the sex offender registry
is preventing subsequent sexual offences
I I would be interested in getting that
data I don't know but what I can tell
you is that there's nothing unique about
sex offending sticking with you after
you are out of prison because we have a
lot of mechanisms in society that do the
exact same thing
all right thank you so much for the call
appreciate it great great to hear from
people at UMass a lot of exciting things
going on at UMass that's for sure